what do we call you sir first name mr.
last name everybody first name mr. last
name class we finally got our first
trailer at comic-con so most of you
probably understand that this is a
sequel to split and unbreakable they
form a trilogy now but there's so many
references back to the original
unbreakable because now we have samuel
l.jackson z-- character back in the mix
and Bruce Willis so the obvious tease is
that samuel l.jackson is saying that
this sounds like the bad guys teaming up
that he's going to be teaming up with
the beast against Bruce Willis's
character so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos it's still the middle of the
summer movie season actually Mission
Impossible is coming up I'll be doing a
review for that really soon - the new
character here at this mental hospital
that's played by Sarah Paulsen is Ellie
staple she's studying these people
believing that they have delusions of
grandeur but mr. glasses whole thing is
is that he wants to show the world that
superheroes are real and even though
they kind of get into the logic of it
during unbreakable they did a much
better job of explaining it from a
scientific perspective during the split
movie with all of James McAvoy's
different personalities during the
comic-con panel M night said that McAvoy
has around 21 distinct personalities
during this glass movie the worst one
like the super aspect of it is the Beast
that's what you see him in the trailer
like you see him in this tunnel here
getting ready to kill these people you
see him climbing on the pipes that's
really like the fullest expression of
his superhero aspect but the other
personalities serve different purposes -
mostly to freak you out and likewise in
the mental hospital he says all we
almost fooled you bro the personalities
all work together in Congress like
there's a cool scene and split where
they're all talking to each other and
it's just James McAvoy transitioning
back between different voices to
distinguish the different personalities
so just from a cinematic perspective
it's an amazing performance I really do
hope that Kevin Feige keeps James McAvoy
around when they go to the MCU era of
the x-men
just because he's a fantastic actor
anyone that can pull off a performance
like that with that many different
personalities is worth keeping around
what seems like is going on here is that
they sort of start bumping into each
other in the
world like you see james mcavoy bump
past bruce willis part of Bruce Willis's
ability is that he can detect when
dangerous coming and helps save people
but he has to touch the person that's
getting ready to do the bad thing
so his spidey sense goes off the charts
when he bumps into James McAvoy alike
something is coming but he's not totally
sure what's going on and it seems like
the movie opens letting you know what
he's been doing this whole time because
it's been a long time since unbreakable
came out the way he explains it in the
trailer like being a security person is
basically being a vigilante on the DL
actually trying to do good things with
his powers but obviously a Sarah
Paulsen's character says like the world
just doesn't believe that superheroes
exist the whole idea of unbreakable is
that samuel l.jackson 'he's character
mr. glass was staging
all these big disasters trying to get
Bruce Willis's character to manifest he
didn't know that David done specifically
existed but his great intelligence had
led him to believe that superheroes were
real so by his logic he causes enough
disasters a superhero will rise to the
challenge so that's how he became the
super villain of the story before that
happened he was just a really smart
person who had a really weak body it's
not quite like James McAvoy's character
who actually does have distinct
personalities the beasts personality
having crazy in human-like abilities but
it's all flowing from human biology so
superheroes are real like these aren't
metahumans or anything like that this is
a little bit different from what you
would consider an x-men movie where they
actually do have mutations this is all
based on human evolution like they're
trying to play it in a more real-world
way so even though they're all sitting
here and samuel l.jackson looks really
frail and old and he's not a danger to
anybody he's just crazy smart that's his
real superpower but it's not a
superpower in the way that you see James
McAvoy running on all fours climbing on
pipes when the beasts personality has
taken control of his body I think the
idea with Bruce Willis's character is is
that his strength flows from the same
place that the beasts strength flows
from if you want to I would recommend
going back and re watching the split
movie when James McAvoy's character is
talking to the psychiatrist she goes to
this big explainer about how the human
body can change based on different
chemicals that it excretes explaining a
scientific reason for why the beast can
have
abilities that it does and why Bruce
Willis's character has the abilities
that he does but it's not like they
shoot laser beams out of their eyes or
anything like that so just like mr.
glass during the unbreakable movie was
causing big disasters to get Bruce
Willis to rise to the occasion his big
plan during this movie is to team up
with James McAvoy's beast character to
get the world to recognize the
superheroes really do exist so just
imagine really big crazy action
set-pieces and then over on the side you
have Bruce Willis's character in on a
Taylor joy who's back from split trying
to stop them this moment here with her
standing with these two people after all
hell breaks loose outside the mental
hospital this is David Dunn's son next
to her and the woman is actually mr.
glasses mother like Sarah Paulson trying
to use the people that were closest to
them as part of whatever her therapy
session was you may also notice that
inside mr. glasses comic book store when
they're thumbing through the comic book
pages they depict the events of the
split movie like you see the Beast
character just ripping people apart like
he did during the movie so I'm just
fascinated to see how this all goes down
because I feel like M Knight definitely
did have a really awesome comeback with
split it's a great movie just by itself
but then at the end when we find out
that it's actually a sequel to
unbreakable they just blew everyone's
minds if it wasn't clear on a Taylor
Joyce character also doesn't have any
superpowers but the way that they're
pitting this is that you have the bad
guys teaming up like mr. glass says I
think the idea is that on a Taylor joy
is going to help team up with Bruce
Willis so it's a little more even odds
but in the middle you have Sarah
Paulsen's character who just doesn't
believe anything it'll be interesting to
see what she does later in the movie
when she sees all these abilities
manifest so that's part of the fun is
that you know way more than her
character if you've seen unbreakable and
split the suspense is palpable like okay
we're just waiting for things to explode
as you kind of see later in the trailer
there's still a whole bunch of Comic Con
videos to get through leave all your
requests in the comments below I think
I'm allowed to post my non-spoilery
mission impossible' fallout review so
that should post either later tonight or
early tomorrow morning while you wait
for everything click here to rewatch
that godzilla king of monsters comic-con
trailer and click here to rewatch all
the DC trailers thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
guys tonight what do we call you sir
first name mister last name